[Music]
why yo what's going on everybody
what is
up I need to fix something real quick
hello hello everyone hello welcome
welcome
welcome why doesn't my thumbnail show oh
there it is okay it's showing
now just turn this
on all right oh I'm
stoked 26 minutes
minutes whoa wait a
second oh you guys are like making me
think I'm like it's out what do you mean
I'm late I'm sorry usually get on 30
minutes before I'm two minutes
late
um oh my predictions you know I put them
in my video today I think we see he who
remains and
um oh I I the only thing I'm wondering
right now is like why why just like why
like what we talked about in the live
stream before about he who remains being
bored I actually really like that idea
like he wants to conquer again right so
that's why he did everything but that's
like what that's what we're missing
that's what we're missing
we're we we know he remains we know Loki
is going to like revisit that moment and
he'll he'll technically be back my hair
is crazy
um but why was it all you know like a
part of the plan for he who means you
know that that's that's my question so I
predict you know looky will do the time
Loop thing and he'll
um fix the time Loom ultimately end up
at that same finale basically as episode
one's finale and
then we'll see he who
remains and
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah guys it's it's not late it usually
comes out at 6 6: p.m. Pacific time and
it's only 5:36 Pacific
time
so I
mean y'all are confused y'all are making
me question myself now but it's not yeah
that's what time it normally comes out
we still have 24 minutes to
go the director said there are no more
kangs in the series I don't remember him
saying that but I mean they literally
showed a scene today of he who
remains they literally showed it today
of he who remains they they and they
showed he who remains and Loki and them
at at the
finale
so yeah I
mean it should it's not Del late it's uh
you guys are early
yeah it's 900 p.m. eastern time uh 6:00
p.m. Pacific time it's definitely uh
definitely not
delayed definitely not
delayed
uh no it's not out yet guys it's not out
yet guys nothing's delayed this this is
weird what what is this crazy rumor
going on it'll come out in 23 minutes so
what are what
are
M mahul that's pretty much what's going
to happen I believe um I see some like
L3 some people saying uh you know King
Prime do we get the king Prime man I
don't I don't know in all honesty like I
don't know are we gonna see a king Prim
I think the Council of kings are the
king primes right the three main
ones and they could be
past present and future versions of
themselves right they could actually be
the same person on the same trajectory
just different points in time so yeah
uh yeah yeah what's up Joe what's going
on thanks for being
here yeah so dropping at nine yes
guys uh yeah I can't speak for India
farad yeah not not really sure not
really sure
um but we have 22 minutes for us here in
the US now my hair kind of look stupid
there we go
um yeah I see a few comments about Kang
Prime y'all I
don't I think if we see a king Prime
what it's gonna be is it's going to be
like the king Trio or maybe he who
remains is trying to become king see
again it goes back to like this question
it's like if if everything really is a
part of he who remains his plan which I
believe it is like why did he do
everything
so
yeah oh AC Valentine time change yes if
y'all if some of y'all didn't get the
time change yet uh if y'all haven't
changed the time on your stuff then then
yeah because it's 6:39 right now and it
normally comes out at
so
yeah I don't
think
yeah what what I'm so con you guys are
confusing me what do you mean MCU
delayed
talk Billy Bug entertainment what's
going on dude
uh are you guys talking about the show
being delayed
because yeah I don't know what's going
on I don't know what's
happening
what is going on with
my am
I oh there we go okay yeah it's
fixed okay hey thanks Jung Gaz
appreciate that what's going on
everybody what's going
on yeah I I don't know uh yeah hey don't
spoil the Marvels for people in the chat
I didn't see I haven't seen it yet um
uh I don't think I don't let me pull up
the chat so I can delete comment I don't
see any
spoilers
uh yeah sorry I'm looking for the spoil
I I saw a couple people say spoilers and
I can't find the spoiler comment to
delete it so that's my
bad hey no spoilers for the Marvels I
haven't actually seen the Marvels
because they didn't do a premere they
just did screenings but if you can hear
I'm still kind of sick um so I didn't go
to the screening in LA because I wasn't
about to one fly there and um be on a
plane while I'm sick and get other
people sick and then get people sick at
the premiere or at the at the screening
wasn't about to do that uh oh delay okay
yeah delay the four movies yeah yeah
yeah okay but people kept saying like
delayed in the chat I thought everybody
was talking about the episode was being
delayed tonight thank you Billy Bug
entertainment for the super chats and
explaining because I was like I guess
that's why I was so confused I was like
how is the episode delayed it's not even
out yet yeah yeah the the MCU delay I
mean I think at this
point it doesn't like it shouldn't
surprise anybody body if if if anything
gets delayed cuz we've had the strikes
both the strikes I know they're both you
know over now but you got to
realize a lot gets a lot gets messed up
during those during these times right
when you
can't
hello hello okay sorry what the heck my
headset died
and yeah my headset died
sorry uh
yeah uh yeah thanks Jason I just saw
your comment yeah still a tiny bit sick
I'm like almost fully recovered but I
haven't I haven't seen the Marvels yet I
was going to go after this tonight but
I'm still not feeling 100% I think I'll
go tomorrow um I believe everyone can
hear me now though
right hello hello hello right
yeah okay cool cool cool back chat's a
little delayed for me sorry about 20
seconds L Ian l03 thanks for that Super
Chat chat excuse
me you saw last vid are that I think
they already cast recast King you think
that without knowing Jonathan's trial
not sure what vid you're talking about I
do think they're going to wait till
Jonathan Major's trial is complete to
actually recast them they do have plans
to recast them meaning they are prepared
for him to be found guilty right in case
he is found guilty they are prepared for
that and they have plans in play place
ready to go so that that's what I meant
I'm not sure what video you you watch
cuz I I've done a bunch of videos on it
um but I'll just tell you now basically
what I just said I I know they have
plans in place they're they're prepared
for anything basically but if he's found
innocent they're G they're going to keep
him and if they don't I I can't imagine
that they that they would get rid of him
after he's found or if he's found
innocent and if they did that would be a
huge in just jce like
wow
yeah uh NOP no updates on the Madam web
trailer not really sure about that yeah
sorry
yeah yeah hey no spoilers about the
Marvels guys for those who've seen it uh
early
um I do know what it is I I know the
whole movie right I always I you
know my Myan Channel started based on
leaks right I and I still do I still
know all of that I still know everything
I still talk to people you know like I
know people I literally know people at
Marvel right so
uh yeah so I I know the whole entire
movie I I know everything that happens
um plus I sent somebody in my place as
well uh to to see the movie for me I
sent law who's been on the podcast and
he's goingon to be doing some other
stuff for the channel as well um I'm
always going to be the one who's talking
about Marvel uh but we are going to
start talking about some other stuff
just some you know cool big movies that
I want to talk about like like Godzilla
and stuff like there's some movies out
there that I really like that I'd really
love to talk about and break down so
Law's gonna help me with that as well so
he went to see the Marvel's and he told
me everything and I'm like oh cool it's
exactly what I heard it was and the the
post credit scenes are exactly what I
thought they were you know all that
stuff uh yeah yeah so haven't seen it
yet
I know all about it
though yeah how's it going everybody
welcome welcome welcome welcome uh see a
few people asking about the release time
should be 14
minutes should
be should be 14
minutes
uh I did I see the new Inside Out
trailer no I did not did that come out
today oh my gosh did the Avatar trailer
finally come out I did not see that is
that
out did anybody did anybody did anybody
see
that wasn't it supposed to come out
today three hours ago
avatar the Last Air vender has anybody
seen it
I it's got to be better than the last
thing we saw
right why do I have zero sound I have no
oh I can't hear in this oh hold on
that's gonna be a
problem uh oh I gotta get my sound ready
for
Loki oh it's amazing oh people are
saying looks good okay good good good so
it's not like the last one okay okay
okay I got to get my uh sound right and
get everything for uh the finale in 13
minutes
here put this
here okay I'm looking at I'm looking at
the trailer a little bit right now and
uh yeah I uh okay this already looks
like a lot better that's
awesome that's
awesome
that's so
cool I'm really excited for this I like
the cast a lot I think I think they did
like a really good job with the cast for
it so so but like this is something you
know that I would love to talk about as
well on on the channel right so all
right we're gonna get everything
ready for Loki let's just tune on the
Disney
plus oh I'm excited all all right so
what what what is everybody what do what
does everybody think's going to happen
here what's what does everybody thinks
happens here sorry I gotta like monitor
the chat at the same time uh but Joe Joe
I know you're there mod yeah just get
rid of any real spoilers of anybody
posted in there for me please I've got
Loki pulled up
here I'm going to pull out a separate
chat here as well so I can also delete
things cuz we don't want anybody
spoiling
anything here pull this
out move to New window and then size it
down
cool oh wait you know what I can
just got it
cool
cool no I not I no I I haven't started
watching uh genin v no no no I know I'm
so
behind I I'm watching something right
now and I don't want to say what it is
because I know people will put spoilers
in the comments the second that I say
I'm in the middle of this but as soon as
I finish I'll make an a I'll make an
announcement of what I'm currently
watching something that ended like
uh a couple years ago
maybe a couple years ago I that I just I
was so busy just with life and
everything I never I never got a chance
to really dive into this uh this series
and uh I
I I finally H again I I I want to say
what it is but I don't want to say what
it is because I think people are going
to start posting spoilers of like this
happens this happens or like this person
dies some something you know I'm not GNA
say too much but uh Five Nights at
Freddy is that
a I thought that was a movie not a
series I'm watching a series like a long
like a long
series long Ser right
now
so yeah some some of you one of
you has guessed
it some of you are
off some are you are a little bit
off
the boys is better than Jin v
h uh Caleb what I hope happens in
Spider-Man freshman year you know I just
want something really fresh I think you
can do a lot with animation you know I
think you can get it's just when you
have the ability to
just when you're not restricted by
filming right and it's animation you
could do so much so I'd really love to
just see some something fresh and some
really cool animation from it I I think
what I hope for in general now moving
forward with like every Marvel
series W with with with everything um is
is better but also great writing because
I feel like that's with the exception of
Loki with the exception of what we're
about to watch in nine minutes but uh uh
with the exception of Loki I feel like
we've just been missing good writing
and yeah I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say too much about the Marvels I
will do a review on it um I want to
watch it for myself make my own
opinion because I I've you know I've
heard everyone's opinions on it you know
I've uh and I've talked to my friends
who have seen it at the the screen I was
supposed to be at but since I was sick I
wasn't there
um I just want to see it first I I don't
want to I don't want to form my own
opinion although I I've heard what
people who often times think like me
have said about it
so yeah uh Jason serious question both
have been amazing but do you think the
Thor should have somehow been involved
at some
point so here here's kind of my thing
about
that uh no and Thor is my favorite MCU
character although
I I'd argue Loki is my favorite
character now um
yeah I just love the The Arc and the
progression of of Loki but I think Kevin
figy said
it with one division he was like you
know these stories are very much about
the main characters who they are so like
in one
division we thought CIO like dror
strange is going to come in Spider-Man
was going to come in something like that
Kevin F's like look the show's called
One Division it's about one division
right and then you have and then you
have a a villain right and it's the same
thing
with I I think anything right it's about
the character like Falcon and the Winter
Soldier was about the Falcon Soldier
Loki is about Loki I I wouldn't have
minded like Loki is in the TVA and at
some point a Thor variant comes in like
that would have been funny but should
like the actual Thor be involved in this
story I actually don't think so I think
this is a lowkey story and Thor is off
doing his own thing right Thor had his
own story we saw that in love and
thunder
so
yeah everybody keeps saying the delay
and I think it's just a hot star delay
unfortunately uh soorry people in
India
uh really
sorry but I don't I think we're about to
watch this in six
minutes I don't see anything about the
the the episode being delayed I know
blade was delayed um I know Thunderbolts
is delayed and Captain America and
Deadpool like I know all that stuff was
delayed uh very very recently like
within within the hour it was all
delayed
um
and from what I've
heard everything else is delayed because
of Captain America I think it didn't
test very well is something that I read
um
yeah so we only get one movie in 2024
and that's uh Deadpool
now but I don't see anything about the
Loki finale being delayed so hot star so
everyone in India I'm sorry and and
wherever else uses hot star I'm not sure
where else uses hot star I think you
guys might be a little
behind so sorry um you guys might have
to
bounce you guys might have to bounce
when the when it starts for us because
we will be watching it in five minutes I
I do apologize to everybody in India for
whatever whatever is caused in delay
obviously it wasn't my fault
but yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've been waiting for a
while hey the proud Canadian thanks for
that Super Chat oh who are my top
favorite five
favorite okay you don't got to Super
Chat again but but I'm curious like in
general or in the MCU I'll just I'll do
the MCU uh I'm gonna I'm gonna say Loki
actually Loki's
really Loki is really up there for me
now I think Loki's well I guess I don't
have to do number one but top five these
are the top five I guess in no
particular order Loki Thor
Spider-Man oh man it's it now it's hard
to Scarlet
witch who would I put for five I guess
Iron Man
yeah Loki Thor Spider-Man Scarlet Witch
Iron
Man that's what I'd go with if we're
talking in general that's completely
different we're talking Dr Doom we're
talking Wolverine like if we're you know
comics and everything like that uh Dr
Doom Wolverine
Spider-Man
uh Cyclops oh that's even that's like
really hard Phoenix you know Jean Gray
Phoenix Force Scarlet Witch again
uh yeah I don't know if I could I don't
know if I can arrow that down to top
five oh that might that one might be a
hard one I have a lot
of Adam Warlock in the comics who is way
different than what we saw in Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 I kind of understand why
they did it but
still uh Glenn boy thank you for that
Super Chat and yes okay so it's a good
question does anyone else find timelines
versus different universes confusing has
each Universe Got an internal
Multiverse so i' I've talked about this
in a few a few videos
like this is something that they're
really not clear on I interpret it as
each timeline is a new
universe could it be different yeah
sure but they haven't explained it to us
yet really they haven't tolded it to us
in in any different way so I don't know
okay there's two minutes um Everybody
Get I need to do I need to get a timer
up actually hold on so everybody get
ready we're going to start this together
like we always do I have it here I'm
just going to refresh to make sure it's
not out
yet I'm GNA
cough
um I really really want to go turn my AC
down cuz it's hot so give me one second
but besides that I think we're good to
go in one minute uh for those asking for
my predictions I do
think we've tapped a new window thank
you I do think Loki is going to take
over the TVA one second I'm gonna turn
my AC
down
we back all
right less than one minute Le Barry
thanks for the Super Chat thinks
himsworth Thor and Deadpool will appear
setting up Deadpool 3 King Dynasty also
get grants Loki and alligator Loki and
Phil that would be tight all of that
would be tight I hope
I hope I I I don't know man I I do hope
we get a post credit and I do hope it's
like yeah like Deadpool or something
like setting it up all right at seven I
have refreshed is it
here come on it is
out it's called glorious purpose and I
have been stating for a while that
Loki's glorious purpose was to take over
the
TVA but let's start this you ready we're
gon to start it in three two one hit
play and we're going into it we are in
it okay hold on let
me we are going through the recap right
now we are watching the recap look put
it right here we're going through the
recap oh oh my gosh I cannot wait for
the finale oh I cannot wait to see what
happens I cannot wait to see what
happens he says I end up right back here
anyways I want to know what it all means
did he mean I'll literally see you soon
or did he mean his variance oh my gosh I
can't wait this is insane oh I'm so
happy I'm so happy right now this is
awesome this is
awesome we're still in the recap right
now here you go we're still watching the
recap oh and now we are in it and now we
are in it oh gosh okay here we
go wait where' my chat
go oh that music though be hit
hard I have a little spider gwy uh phone
holder so I'll put my chat
here put it right
here episode is out y'all we are
watching it right
now
and he's gonna just time glitch right
back in
see and he's just gonna get right back
in right before Victor timley
died and we hear the alarm all right we
hear the
alarm
time to be
brave I wonder if Victor's gonna
actually
be be bad oh okay all right here we go
here we go here we
go he's
back we have to get timely out
there he's going to let him die
again oh because he has to find out what
they did
wrong he yes so he's going to literally
let him die
again they're GNA let him die
again and
then
okay so now Loki is just gonna be like
yeah he died cool what do we do
differently next
time yeah
okay what could we have done there here
yeah
that's so he's like okay now we got to
go back again oh this is GNA be awesome
faster go yes go oh my gosh this is
awesome the music for this everything oh
my gosh let's do
it
Loki you got to go back sooner than
further than
[Laughter]
that not faster earlier
exactly
[Laughter]
and just you're just hearing Victor
timely scream over and over again
oh
dude this is
hilarious that
music he's going so fast now oh my
gosh oh my gosh look how cute these guys
are this is
fantastic th this is Fant fantastic I
mean I can't this is so
funny cuz you fall you did you will
that's hilarious oh my gosh this is
[Laughter]
awesome
o
oh and I'm a God I love
it I think I'm a little I think my timer
is a little ahead slow it
down
decades
centuries so what
happens centuries
later he literally took all the time he
literally took hundreds of years to
learn
everything that's
amazing that's
amazing and
he wow that's amazing this is great
riding man this is just great
riding
yeah you gotta
go it's him it's you you volunteered
that's so
funny so this Loki right here is
literally hundreds of years old now I
mean I already was but even
more
seems like Loki has seen a lot of
uh Loki has done a lot of different
scenarios man look at this this is
insane this is great
riding they'll get bigger
he's done this so many times now it's
amazing that is great oh my
gosh dude
what
what's going on with my
hair wow
man what what what great
writing does he make it this time does
Victor T Loki is going to realize that
he has to do
it oh maybe not
oh oh he's getting
through no he's gonna
die no he's gonna
die
look he's like you're being so brave
these are kids to him now he's like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
years
old
oh do not put it
down gosh how many times has he done
this the question is does it
work does it work
[Music]
work I think Loki's going to realize
that it doesn't have to be Victor it can
be Loki he knows more than Victor timely
knows
now green button green
button hit the green
button oh
oh oh okay okay okay okay okay okay hoof
it you're gonna have to hoof it back
dude
hoof it
back hoof Huff
it I don't know if it is gonna work this
time come on Victor oh he made it he
made made it shut the door shut the door
did he really make it that
time you're the door is not completely
shut
yet it's okay it is shut does he
live why is OB OB looks confused it's
not working oh it is
working oh the Rings are
expanding
something's got to happen
though something's got to happen right
actually no it has to happen so Loki can
take over the
TV he said it worked Wizard or did it
work
wizard now does Victor kill
everyone
uh
oh here we go what's happening what's
happening it's
overloading
oh he's going to have to go back to the
end of time and meet he who
remains too many too many
branches so you do have to prune
some
at an infinite
rate is
he oh the the loom has to scale
infinitely
uh you can't scale for something
infinite trying to divide by
zero why does it need a loom I don't
understand why does the Multiverse need
a
loom so the TVA can control it I
guess
now you're gonna go back to the Citadel
of the end of time he's going back to
the Loki season 1
finale the limit does not exist oh God
that's hilarious that's so
funny hey Dar how's it going
he has he has to go back to the Citadel
at the end of
time wait what did Victor Tomley just
say there I didn't I didn't hear what he
said I mean Loki can go back but these
yeah here it is here it is here it is
he's gonna go back oh my gosh oh my
gosh
[Music]
okay this is intense is he gonna enchant
her
no wait is that him or is that is he
somewhere watching this
oh here he goes now he's
that oh
wow
he's gonna stop him from killing
him does he have to kill Sylvie does he
have to kill kill
[Laughter]
Sylvie I want to know if this is all a
part of the
plan see he's way too calm oh he kills
her he's gonna realize that he has to
kill
Sylvie dude poor poor King variants they
just keep dying and dying and dying and
dying
see he who remains knew that was going
to happen right
there
oh he's gonna have to kill her that's
this is going to be so
sad he can't kill her he just keeps
letting
why do you never try to stop
her he froze
her so how many times has you been at
this you haven't learned out of PA time
yet I figured you'd be way past that
cuz he planned it
all yes I knew it he's behind
everything
I knew
it I knew
it and then whoop I knew it was his
[Music]
plan he never
died so so what was the
why reincarnation
baby
so
go through it a couple thousand more
times
oh ly get control
time
[Laughter]
you're my
favorite Victor timely that's so
funny
everything was a part of the
plan
the sa the sacred timeline
okay wow man it is out right now
guys there's too many variants
remains that's
funny you
lose
wow I know he says I know I know he he
loses
wow uh I think the episode's like 56
minutes long
ooh
I was here alone at the end of time this
is amazing look at
this keeping watch
you want to break
the I made the tough choice that's why I
get the the big
chair what are you offering Loki
specifically though
looky wants to find another way and he
who remains is just like
dude and now sylv's back
and around and around and around we
go break the loom you cause the war
kills or kill
her
oo so he can either start a multiversal
war
or he can kill
Sylvie now we're now we're back to
episode one of Loki season 1 what is
this
what
wow
what this is taking a
turn
oh
what proper flow of
time
dang eight-year-old
boy this too
late
more burden than
Glory how do you live with the bird
Scar
Tissue oh he was that
guy
oh this is
deep there's no comfort you just choose
your burden
wow
wow now he's gonna shake his hand and
just time GL no I'm tired of seeing
Mobius
die so now
what you're just going to sit there in
that void oh my gosh they're showing us
him getting spaghettified again
he freezes okay okay
okay is
he oh he's outside
time
wow does he have
to I mean he's went ad of her hundreds
of
years
yep
MH he has to kill
Sylvia what is she going to
say I'm not giving you my
blessing
I'm ly I'm the god of
Mischief sometimes it's okay to destroy
something
[Music]
you have to control the TVA Loki that is
what has to happen bro just left her
there to die by the way he may not have
killed the real Sylvia but he just
killed that
variant
okay so he has to go out there and do
something because we've seen that the
trailer preview of him walking out on
the platform right
so so Loki walks out and does something
I mean
like o
he's going out
there I know what kind of God I need to
be
o uh this is like this episode's amazing
for those
asking
what is what is happening what is going
on what is he gonna do what what could
he possibly
do what could I don't understand what
could he possibly do
though oh my gosh oh oh my god oh he's
going back in
time time is going through his body he's
young
now
what oh no no oh my
gosh what is
happening no
way
and he's he's going to break
it
what oh my gosh those freaking horns
so he destroyed the time Loom but he
saved the
TVA so now
what holy
crap what
is what is he gra
what is he in he Enchanted the oh my
gosh
what is he trying to enchant the
branches what is happening
here
what the heck is he
doing this really is Loki god of stories
he's just gonna write it
all oh my gosh look at that
shot what is he
doing he he's going to to become he who
remains
yep that's it look he's going to the
Citadel at the end of time out of
time he's going to become he who
remains
wow
what
what he's giving us a chance
what oh my
gosh
is he gonna what is he gonna create when
he's creating
it Loki god of stories look at this
holy
crap what is
happening I know Jen right oh my gosh
this is amazing
holy
crap
what the hell is going
on what did he
do what is
that
no
way
what what is this after
after let's grow together nurture
what
Loki like is the Multiverse now the
world tree right like you Dr
yeah
Mobius is just sitting
there oh the variance of her remains who
are they who are
they 616 adjacent realm
what
your file as requested what did I can't
uh what did it say on
it
adjacent were you leaving
ovus
with a heart of
gold
go right a ji
Mobius go ride that jet
ski
I mean someone will look out for you the
TVA can look out for
you for all time
always
who the heck are all these
people
oh TVA official handbook second edition
wow
does he get a is somebody gonna give a
kid k a second oh no no one gives him
anything no one gives Victor timely
anything raana rensler you at you in the
void she's in the
void it's like no it's not empty cuz
there was a pyramid there obviously
but was the TVA pruned
what
is someone coming for
her oh no it's elath
ah we're on the same
team is he watching himself or is that
him he's watching
himself oh s's
there the yard could do a bit
work
for
well let time pass something he could
never do before because the TVA was
outside of
time
[Music]
what so
Loki
he he controls
everything wow he's just
there
what that is
crazy wow
wow well all
right all right well that
uh that blew me
away that that blew
me
away
wow I I that that
is it's like kind of the direction I
thought they were going to go but in
like it just like so much better than I
thought actually like I this is the
first time in a long time for me where I
think Marvel
way outdid my expectations for
something I just I
I
uh I'm just so blown away right
now
I
so yo Loki became the Tree of Life at
the end um I I don't actually know how
to pronounce it it's it's like y y g g d
r a s i l igdrasil igdrasil anybody who
speaks Norse uh tongue can help me out
there if anybody I think it's in the
Captain America movie right I think they
like talk about it I can't remember
um
uh but but yeah I mean it's it's the
tree of life and it's basically
like uh you know it's it's Norse
mythology which is really cool and it's
basically like it encompasses all of
like all of the
worlds uh in you know like all of the
branches and stuff of the tree are
worlds right that that create it
um it yeah so it has like all I think
it's like they have nine nine worlds
nine
Realms um in it in noris mythology and
isn't that what you know Odin says in
the in
the
uh in the movies right he's like the
nine Realms right I think that's what he
talks about but basically yeah that's
here let's go ahead and look up the
Norse mythology
like stuff about it let's see what like
actual Norse mythology says let's uh
let's see what Norse mythology
says y g g d r a s i
l has anyone been able to tell me how to
say it
yet I know it's a tree of life it's a
sacred tree like I I know that but I
don't know how to say this in Norse
igdrasil
is how I'm going to say it y g d r a s i
l is an immense and Central sacred Tree
in Norse cosmology around it exists all
else including the nine worlds igrl is
attested in the poetic Eda comp okay
hold on blah blah blah blah I won't bore
you the gods go to idrasil daily to
assemble at their traditional governing
assemblies the branches of ignal extend
far into the heavens and the tree is
supported by three roots that extend far
away into other
locations one is the Ora Broner in the
heavens one spring velir and another to
the well mmus
Bruner interesting but basically it is
kind of like the center of the universe
also what holds the universe all
together
um so essentially Loki has
become the
Multiverse
like which is
insane so now it is kind of
like it was shown in the original Thor
movie that's what what I was thinking of
then I know yeah I know they showed
something or I know they showed like
something of it in one uh in one MCU
movie I thought it was I thought it
might have been in in Captain America
maybe the first Captain America I
thought maybe right no am I thinking of
something
else
but they did in Thor it's been a while
since I've seen Captain America or the
Thor movie I'm trying to like go over in
my head now uh
yeah but basically he's like the center
of the universe now like he is the
Multiverse which is
like like if you guys watch my videos
you've been in live chats you've heard
me saying like Loki asked to take over
the TVA
like this is this is way more than I
actually thought it would be like and
you want to talk about a glorious
purpose holy crap a glorious purpose to
literally he literally
saved like everything truly gave people
people Free Will which is
really really funny and like the
best it's like the best
Arc for Loki that could be written
like what did we say before this the
episode started like what are you hoping
for this and I I said good
writing and like because I feel like
that's been lacking lately not with Loki
but with Marvel in general and I think
this this just exceeded my expectations
by all means I
mean like the his glorious purpose like
wow I mean to be to now essentially be
the Multiverse and holding it together
and what's interesting is the TVA was
still dealing with Kang conqueror so
kind of like I thought before was kind
of like
hey you know looki takes over the TVA
and then they monit monor these
timelines for Kang variant and they try
to get them before they they get out of
hand that's how you that's how you give
people free will but stop the
multiversal war at the same time by
monitoring all the timelines with the
TVA but I thought Loki was going to take
over the TVA instead he takes over like
the entire Multiverse and like becomes
the Multiverse himself which is like
insane Oho thanks so much for that Super
Chat a thank you so much I I appreciate
that I appreciate you being here each
week uh and I I hope I'm better in a day
or so but thanks for being hereo
appreciate it you've always been
chatting and super chatting thank you so
much it really appreciate you oh man uh
okay we have a lot of people in chat
right now so go ahead spam It Out rated
out of 10 nine out of 10 10 out of 10
100 out of 10 what does everybody think
because to me that was just like that
that was
probably this this finale this ending
that moment where Loki just goes I know
what I have to do and he walks out there
he just he that was probably it's
definitely top five MCU moments for me
I'm trying to think of
like what is better than that moment the
very first Avengers movie where it's
like circling all of them are together
and then you
have Avengers
Assemble and and that and then that
moment right there with Loki
that's and thank you for that super chat
doesn't that mean he can stop any bad no
point in at Kang or any other big bad
even what does this mean for Kang I I
don't
think I don't think he really interferes
and I think that's the entire point I
think he
literally he took it from he who remains
because he who remains
was restricting it
to one sacred timeline right and I think
the the whole deal was how can it
exist
otherwise you know without the time Lo
because the time so what what he said
was like the time Loom is a fail safe so
so there was like two options right so
if you destroy the time Loom it it it
still reverts back to the sacred
timeline I believe is what he said
um I I I believe that is what he's he
who remains said I'll have to go back
and watch it right but um hey what's up
Leon and um
so so destroying the time Loom would
have would have it was a fail safe you
know for the sacred timeline so it would
have just been the sacred timeline and
then if you would have if he would have
let he who remains remain then there's
no Free Will at all so really there was
like no way to win which is what he who
remains with sane there there's like
there's no way to win you know you you
repeat this however many times you want
and then let's have this conversation
but instead Loki was like no neither I'm
not going to do I'm not gonna do any of
these options right I I am G to destroy
the time Loom but I I'm he's gonna kind
of take its spot is what's
crazy so
imf4 te thanks for that Super Chat yeah
so in a way he is kind of Avengers Prime
it's obviously different than uh what
what what Avengers team was it that
became Avengers prime it was like Luke
Cage and some other ones um but yeah
essentially you know in the comics EV
just Prime you have a of Avengers who
fuse together essentially to become one
entity which is Avengers Prime he he is
kind of uh he is kind of like that now
in as the whole embodiment of the
Multiverse
so yeah so so so basically what he chose
going back to you know the whole he
remains took away their free will right
by by pruning everything timeline right
there's no free will which is what
Sylvie was saying at the end like there
there's no free will as long as he who
remains is doing what he does and then
he who remains explained that the time
Loom is a fail safe and it's just going
to go back to the sacred timeline so
either way Loki was going to lose but
instead what Loki did he took over
essentially kind of being the time Loom
itself and is allowing the Multiverse to
just exist now with true free will to
people so that is what Loki just did he
essentially became the Multiverse and he
gave free will to everybody true Free
Will so now nobody is really doing
anything but the TVA like I said the TVA
the the option this is what we talked
about for weeks now the only option
really to have true Free Will is to let
everything Branch but then have the TVA
monitor watch out for Kang variant right
uh Matthew monino thanks to that super
chat so here I was about to get into
this actually what about the K the
Council of Kings though so here's like
the thing right
um kangs and the variant thereof can you
know the ones that are smart not the no
offense to Victor timley we love Victor
timley right he was a great character um
no no offense to to Victor timley but
the smart Kings the ones born in the
31st Century 40th Century whenever what
whatever how far you want to go
so those Kings Still those Kings still
have their smarts have their Tech and
they can go outside of time right so
essentially existing in their own
outside of the lowkey Multiverse that it
is now right so that's what the Kings
come in so there's still going to be
Kings out there and he who remain said
that that that's part of the problem he
who remain said like there's too many
variants and Loki is like I'll find him
and he remains is like you you can't you
can't you you can't there's too many so
essentially loky gave him Free Will Kang
varians are going to pop up the TVA is
going to do the best that they can but
ultimately there are going to be Kang
varians out there that slip through the
cracks exist outside of time and space
exist out of kind of the Multiverse in
general and that's when they're going to
come so when they start going into these
timelines that's kind of where the TVA
is going to have to come in and fight
them and the you know a multiversal
Avengers team hold on just got a Super
Chat where is it Chris G love lowy
multivers looks like the igal tree yeah
no I that's what we've been talking
about we actually looked up the uh the
definition here of that tree and uh
yeah we looked up the actual like Norse
mythology you know it it it around it
exists all else including the nine
worlds is what uh what it says right
here so yeah I
mean Leon you say Rana was sent to Egypt
and that purple light is Kang from
Antman man and the WASP quantam Mania
actually I think that was uh
elath I think it was
elath
so I I don't think uh I don't think that
was Kang from Quantum Mania I think it
was elith and I think she got uh deleted
from
existence so kangs are still out there
guys uh all Loki did was truly give
people Free Will by allowing a true mult
merse to exist like a true Multiverse to
exist so
unfortunately that doesn't prevent kangs
the TVA can do their best
to prevent kangs whether that's just
going to the timeline and literally just
pruning a a timeline or not a timeline a
a a variant of I was going to say timely
a variant of Kang just pruning a variant
of him and that's what they have to do
unfortunately like he remain said
there's too many so that's how we get
the Council of Kings right Loki didn't
get rid of K I don't think Loki controls
the Multiverse I think that's actually
against the point I think the whole
point is Loki gave people free will true
Free Will hey thanks Anthony McElroy
super appreciate that super chat I think
I there was another one Dan thanks for
that Super Chat what happens to Loki now
I think Loki I think he sacrificed
himself I think he he is now that is
what he is he is the he's the
Multiverse right and he's not destroying
any parts of it he is just letting it be
what it
is and he is literally
giving what did Sylvie
say shouldn't they be given a chance to
fight that's what Loki is doing he's not
preventing Kang from coming he's
literally just giving people the free
will to be able to fight for themselves
not just Kang but you know all aspects
of Life hey Leon thanks for becoming a
member again super appreciate that
buddy we got some more members in the
chat scooting syv what's going on oh
you're a gifting membership do thanks so
much man Leon you're the best you gifted
five what's going on Abie bacon Scoot
and sylvus I like it ah Anno I like it I
like it I like it I like
it nice uh Christian surani thanks for
Super Chat do you think his story is
over Willi return so that that's
a that's a good question so I think that
is the major question happening right
now isn't it isn't that the the the the
major question
now is
Loki permanently stuck there so well
okay so here here's the
thought now we have to think about what
happens after Secret Wars and
and AMR ysf Amir ysf thanks for that
super chat I expected to post credit
from Deadpool 3 for Deadpool 3 yeah I
I yeah I I don't I don't know man I
thought so too but they haven't really
been giving us many post credits going
into other things from these Disney Plus
shows have they um oh well thanks for
Super Chat Christopher Lewis thanks for
Super Chat does that mean no more King
no actually I I think that means a lot
more King I think it means a lot more K
Aaron thanks for the Super Chat uh I'll
explain because I realize a lot people
are coming in and out of the chat um I
think what this means is like I don't
think Loki
is he's not preventing Kang right that's
not the deal he is literally holding the
Multiverse together kind of like what
their version of the fixed time Loom was
supposed to do right so essentially Loki
has become a Time Loom
he he can he is just holding it together
he is allowing a Multiverse to exist
without he who remains
ruling one sacred timeline and again if
the time Loom was destroyed in a normal
way it would have just it was a fail
safe for the sacred timeline remember so
it would have just been the sacred
timeline so Loki is literally just
allowing the Multiverse to
exist Does that mean no more kangs no
Loki is not venting King's in fact the
opposite he is he has just opened the
Multiverse up to the Multiverse of War
but it's like Sylvie said he's at least
giving people actual Free Will and
that's the whole point that was the
whole point of Loki episode one or
season one and now season two is to have
actual Free Will and now Loki has it or
now Loki has given it to everybody
Fabian Garcia thanks for that Super Chat
super appreciate that briski 889 thanks
for the Super Chat who would have ever
thought that Loki that got a mischief
would make the ultimate sacrifice to
save the Multiverse I'm saying man I
mean isn't that isn't this the arc for
him it isn't that just the greatest
isn't this just the greatest
thing isn't it like it's just such an
amazing
Arc Cash Money Ron thanks for that Super
Chat thanks for the Cash Money
appreciate that uh Azie Garcia thanks
for Super Chat what was that file Mobius
had yeah so let's take a look at that
because that is actually something I
didn't get a good look at so let's pull
this
up let's let's let's bring this back
right here we're GNA bring it okay
here's a file right
here
um did she give it to them already am I
am I did I go too far back here let me
pull it up on
screen let's pull this
up
all right so let's what does the file
say your file as
requested I can't I can't read it I I
have to take a a screenshot of hold on
uh Buzz Von thank you so much for that
Super Chat love your coverage and takes
MCU how does this could tie into
Deadpool 3 and do we see Loki after
secret War considering soft reboot
actually so okay you brought up a great
point that I was getting into that I got
sidetracked on uh we have to think about
what happens after Secret Wars now uh I
if it's a soft reboot then I think maybe
Loki gets out of it somehow is there a
correlation between Loki and The Watcher
a person thanks for that super chat I
appreciate it uh yeah you know oh Aaron
a thanks for that Super Chat he's become
the Watcher yeah it's kind of you know
in a way yes CU he can't interfere right
because he's giving people true free
will uh Amir ysf thanks for Super Chat
that means this episode is placed before
now way home I think it's kind of placed
outside of time in all honesty um you
could say it's before you could say it's
after you could say it's during I think
that's kind of the point actually uh as
as weird as that as weird as that
sounds hey Mr Anderson dude it was
freaking amazing like way
better than than anything Dan for pitola
hey I was born in Pensacola and I lived
a good amount of my life there what was
the last Ren Slayer scene about I think
elath took her remember elith from the
Loki finale I think that was uh yeah I
think that was elath uh Cash Money Ron
thanks for another one Loki has become
an Ora Boris himself yeah actually yeah
he really has a Snak in his own tail
yeah I
mean it's it's crazy uh LL thanks for
Super Chat the tree at the End of Time
Luke 2129 never thought Marvel would
go that religious yeah well you know
it's also um Norse mythology as well uh
igdrasil I think that's how you say it
somebody tell me how to how how to if
that's wrong uh but but yeah igdrasil
um how can the loom fail save cause a
Time Loop when it wasn't causing a Time
Loop well I think it was just it was
designed by he who remains and that's
just what he had it do I think it's just
he he he made it to where it reverts
back to the sacred
timeline good job Josh thanks for super
chat if he's allowing the Multiverse to
exist how does that play into future
incursions happening in the MCU well
again he's he's not he is not
specifically doing anything with the
multiverses with the timelines with the
universes he is simply allowing them to
exist he is giving free will to
literally everyone in the entire
Multiverse the in the entire Multiverse
so he's not interfering in any way which
is what he who remains was doing that's
so he took the place of he who
remains kind of holding now he's just
holding the Multiverse together but not
interfering at all he he truly gave
people free will which again was the
entire point of Loki season 1 and really
this so incursions are going to happen
to answer your question incursions are
going to happen uh no matter what
because the TVA is not going to be prun
in timelines you know what I mean mean
TVA is not going to be prune in
timelines and that's kind of the whole
point they can do their best to try to
stop the multiversal war and prune cane
variants but yeah uh Ronald sa II did he
become the tree of viil yes I think he
did I very much uh think he did I that's
what we've been talking about I think
that's him now uh Sean Cole's the file
was his life oh thank you yeah I I I
can't
uh it says to it it says names on it but
I can't
I can't make them out I'll have to
screenshot it when I'm on my my Mac and
not my my PC and I'll zoom in and stuff
like that uh but but if you found it
thank you and that makes sense that it's
the case File of his life because
because he wanted to go back home
because or he wanted to you know see see
what his life was like see what his life
was like that's how was okay Adam thank
you so much for the Super Chat that's
how I've been pronouncing it igdrasil
dra drail IG drail maybe it wasn't how
exactly as I was pronouncing it but the
but the the y g is IG right so thank you
for confirming that IG dzil IG Dil thank
you appreciate
that yeah so I mean that's I think that
part is pretty obvious because of the
tree at the end which is like freaking
amazing it becomes zdrazil oh man I I
can't tell you how glad I am with the
writing of this it was amazing the haze
records thanks for the Super Chat so
what's the threat from here can he hold
forever well that's kind of the thing is
is Loi is actually allowing the threats
to exist now he's allowing the
Multiverse to produce variants of Kang
the Conqueror and allowing incursions to
essentially
happen he's just holding it all together
not controlling anything uh so we go
from here into Secret Wars where
incursions start happening a lot that's
where we go from here uh which is
exciting to think about actually cfic
thanks for that big Super Chat amazing
that they ended episode like that it
makes sense ly prevents disaster and
since there's a reported incursion in
Captain Marvel's movie I believe that'll
be the start of the war yeah I think
this is this is it because again he is
just allowing Free Will so incursions
are going to happen and yeah I haven't
seen Captain Marvel yet or the Marvels
yet sorry um but yeah we've been talking
about an incursion in that movie for a
while I don't think that's like a huge
spoiler at this point um the threat of
incursion starts to really hit hard in
that uh in that movie I I I've heard
curry in a cup
so what does the TVA do now do they
still prune things and what happens next
for the group The TVA actually what they
do now is they try to prevent Kang the
Conqueror they try to focus they try to
hunt down the Kang variants that are
becoming Super Evil and Destroy them
that's what the TVA does and I think
they I think they monitor for incursions
I think that's going to be a big part of
uh of what they're going to do as
well Ronald Saul second or beginning of
Avenger Prime that's what we talked
about as as well Loki kind of became
Avenger Prime there um obviously
different story than how the comics with
The Avengers all fusing into one entity
but yeah I mean essentially
um I see what you did there Mr Anderson
excellent let me pull something up here
real quick so I don't oh hold on there
was something else that I wanted to see
in this wasn't there something
this H so I can't I can't make this
out
oh it's Kang you can see her oh that's
quantam mania this is Quant Mania you
can see it right here look look look
look this is this is Kang from quantam
Mania it's it's turned sideways right
it's turned sideways but this is him oh
and this is the device right here this
was that orb that he put in the big
giant device
oh yeah look at that so this is Kang
shooting out beams you can see one beam
here one beam here this is head right
here it's sideways sideways um and then
this is the orb thing the device
yeah
interesting interesting how do I there
we go wow okay okay okay okay um there
was a super chat let me get to
that Jed cares sorry if I didn't
pronounce that right the 616 that Mobius
read and said that they took care of was
it reference quantam Mania right or was
it reference something else it looks
like it's an exact reference to Quantum
Mania yeah it looks like looks like it's
an exact reference to Quantum Mania I
mean look at this right here let me pull
it back up right here I mean yeah look
it's it
it's yeah that's K from Quantum Mania
here let's let's revisit what he said
let let me put the subtitles on
here revisit
I got those reports of the variance of
he who remains sorry you can't really
see it hold on do any of them know that
we exist yet nope look at
that I guess one of them caused a little
bit of ruckus on a 616 adjacent realm so
he's talking about the the the quantum
realm which is crazy he's talking about
the quantum realm there
wow wow okay Fernando Von Chris thanks
for that Super Chat super appreciate
it uh missed one more Jed thanks for
another one okay then I think my
question has been answered should have
read it more
carefully should have read sorry let
me yeah no it it's uh as we can see here
this clearly looks like come let me uh
can I expand this a little bit more for
you guys hold
on I can do this I'm techsavvy
I'm Tech
sa I'm working on it look you guys see
that King from Quantum
Mania and this is the you can kind of
make it out here this is that the orb he
used to power everything
right
yeah orb he used to put in that device
right here right and then yeah
interesting oh what oh my mou else is
over
there wow that's so
cool put that here
wow man
I I'm blown away that that's how they
that that's what they went with I'm
blown away I think you all heard me
talking for a while talking about how
Loki has to take over the TVA but I
don't think I ever imagined
him being the universe to give everyone
Lal free
will yeah
so I I think I
think you know if they are doing an MCU
reboot then we we're GNA run into Loki
again at some point and and I would like
to think maybe in secret Wars or
something I would like to think that
somebody tells Thor what his brother did
right I
mean right wouldn't that be amazing
well speaking of Kevin Ardo than for
Super Chat well my Thor Loki reunion is
dead yeah that kind of I don't know
right I I would like clearly Loki can
can see everything happening he saw
Mobius at the end there so who knows
Fernando V Chris thanks for another one
Aaron Morehead and Benson should direct
Secret Wars yeah I
mean I I'm reluctant to say this but uh
you know the russer brothers said they
would come back and they did a good job
L of films than they would do but I'm
definitely open to good writers because
you this is a perfect example of what
great writing can do it's so
good uh Johnny Herrera Jr thanks for
that super CH chat I'm Victor timely now
how do you think the TVA fits into
Deadpool 3 then I thought they were the
ones going after Deadpool because he's
time traveling well I still
think I still think that's going to be
uh a thing right I just they're not
pruning timelines anymore so like Loki
time traveled and then they pruned that
entire timeline I don't think that's how
it works anymore I think they let that
live uh so they might not be capturing
people anymore I personally think that
they're just going to be monitoring Kang
variants or anybody who's really causing
harm to the Multiverse that that's how I
think the TVA is going to fit into it so
I think they're going to play a big part
in um managing Kang right they're going
to prune instead of pruning timelines
they're going to prune
Kang uh Justin kff thanks for that Super
Chat super appreciate
it a person thanks for the Super Chat
how does the Antman 4 credits scene tie
into this Antman
4 have we had for Ant-Man 3 um what were
oh the Council of Kings sorry it took me
the Council of Kings um so the Council
of
Kings is
only existing right now because of this
and so as we see here right this is Kang
from Quantum Mania right right
here yeah that's the only reason that
any of the stuff happened from Quantum
Mania including the post credit scene is
because of what Loki did Loki made the
Multiverse exist Loki is the Multiverse
which is freaking crazy please don't
tell me they just erased Jonathan Majors
where is Marvel going with the storyline
uh I I think if anything they just
created a lot more of him with all the
Kang variants in all honesty uh
appreciate the Super Chat Ronin uh
because we're still going to get
incursions and there and and he who
remains told Loki because Loki said like
I'll kill all the king variants and Kang
he who remains was like there there's
too many it's infinite there's too many
can't and Loki's like I I'll try and he
remains is like look come back go
through this time Loop a bunch more and
then essentially when you figured it out
that there is no other way let's talk
but looky figured out another way by
becoming the
Multiverse uh Cory Allen thanks for
Super Chat at the end one of the
timelines lit purple and something was
said as the camera zoomed on Loki's
face let's take a
look
um I didn't see
it I I think I think he was watching
Mobius and Sylvie talk I think that's
what it was I I think he was hearing
that I don't think it was like like Kang
like purple purple light from Kang the
Conqueror or something like that but
good good catch there was definitely
some voices there I think it's the voice
of sylv and mobus though uh Johnny
bretti thanks for the Super Chat love
the vids where can I get that Miss
minutes hat oh this one right here um
Marvel sent it to me sorry they sent me
like a whole box with a bunch of uh Loki
stuff like these cute little Loki
bracelets and
stuff guess you can't
see uh
so sorry I I don't I don't know I can
imagine you look online for one
though uh thank you for that Super Chat
let me see if I sure I miss some saw a
few here let me take a look okay cool I
don't think I did if I missed any super
chats I'm really sorry I will go through
them let me actually pull that up on the
back end of YouTube right now just to
make sure it didn't miss
any but yeah oh my gosh guys I just
can't tell you
how
satisfied I am
with this
ending I can't I
mean it was so
good so
good I'm going through the Super Chat
make sure I didn't miss any I I don't I
don't think I
did yeah so Loki is you know the the
there's a bunch of things you can say
now the tree at the end time igd
dzil uh the tree of life I mean he
essentially essentially he is the
Multiverse Sean Cole thanks for the
Super Chat the T that timeline died
Sylvia survived with her band are you
talking
about are you talking about the end
where
everything disa everything disappeared
and I was was like oh he let Sylvie die
in that in that Brand's timeline not too
sure what you're talking about sorry I
apologize Daniel crane why didn't Loki
just spend centuries studying Sylvie and
stopping he remains instead of allowing
it also what about timekeepers uh eke
keepers are fake they never they were
never real um so don't think about them
um I think Loki did spend a lot of time
studying it and I think that's when he
was speaking to he who remains and he
was like he remains is like yeah let me
know when you figure it out there
there's two options you destroy the time
Loom right and it and it's a fail safe
and it just gives you one sacred
timeline um
or well three options I guess destroy
the time Loom so it's just a sacred
timeline um kill him
and you know everything goes crazy and
it doesn't work it eventually ultim
ultimately killing him does result in
the time Loom dying exploding which
would result in the sacred timeline uh
or kill
Sylvie and essentially rule with him the
timeline so Loki chose none of those
options Loki chose to become the
Multiverse and give him Free Will and
give everybody free will uh buvan thanks
for Super Chat can we consider Loki he
who remains and can we get a fit rating
for he remains Loki also potential Thor
and Sylvie Meetup is going to be awkward
yeah I I'm thinking about how I really
want somebody to tell Thor what his
brother did like you know like you you
have no idea what your brother did he he
gave everybody Free Will in like every
single Universe everywhere like I want I
want that U and I would kind of consider
Loki he who remains just a a better
one yeah
yeah for
sure uh can you zoom
in on the king file more see what it
says I was trying uh unfortunately on
this computer I can't really
um let me
try I can pull it up a little bit uh
bigger on the on this on the chat here
Matthew you think for Super Chat he
remains correcting Victor was hilarious
it really was that was really though
this this whole it was amazing uh hold
on Captain Red Bull if Loki cannot only
see into the Multiverse but also project
himself into them he could be make a lot
of C in the future yeah if he could
project himself into them I wonder if he
could it would make sense kind of that
he could um so yeah I mean I would love
for a lot of Loki cameos in the future
um J pal I wish we saw more Loki
variants me too I really do I really do
thanks for Super Chat um with the Loki
cameos I feel like he would have
projected
himself
into that scene with sylv and Mobius if
he could so maybe he can't but you know
he is the god of mischief and now he is
the Multiverse itself so don't put it
past him
um sorry let me just refresh this
here uh I'm I'm missing some I will zoom
in on the king file more just give me a
second I don't want to miss any super
chats and I feel like I did
yeah that's it she know why he runs out
to save
her ah gotcha okay yeah I see what
you're saying now yeah okay that makes
sense I agree with you
then I thought Loki would wolf be the
Tony Stark The Saga this is only middle
chapter right it makes sense if he'll be
one that kills the main King yeah maybe
man you we really don't know I I don't
think we're done with Loki I don't think
he is gone I think think we're going to
see him again I I definitely think we're
going to see him
again um is this not showing me all my
super
chats uh I don't know maybe he did try
it and we didn't see Loki killing him
Diego thanks for the super chat um but I
think he just realized that if he K if
he kills Sylvie then essentially he who
remains still rules the sacred timeline
and Free Will doesn't exist and that
wasn't an option right that just wasn't
an option he had to he had to make it to
where Free Will existed so okay it it's
YouTube is not showing me all the super
chats so I'm going to scroll through the
actual chat right here to see any I
missed I do apologize why isn't it
showing me all
this okay uh shayana King thanks for
Super Chat I love that he formed them
into igdrasil and truly had his glorious
purpose finally no I it's like the best
thing that could have ever freaking
happened for him right I mean it's it's
like it's
amazing I I love it too thanks for the
Super Chat Allison Thompson so what
happens to he who remains how was able
how was Loki able to do this because he
is a God I mean definitely because he
was a God and yeah I think he went so he
went back in time to where he who
remains was actually dead right so
Sylvie killed him and that's when Loki
you know started time slipping he came
back and everything you
know started going wrong and the time Lo
was going to explode so Loki essentially
got rid of the time Loom and took its
place and became kind of the center of
the of the Multiverse there so he
remains I would say is
gone Cliff The Dark Knight does this
mean major stays as king oh man you know
I don't think they've decided de
unfortunately uh I don't think they've
decided yet I think it depends on the
trial but I hope he does acorn tree
thanks for that super chat so would you
say he's like the god of stories and the
comics I don't think he's writing any of
the time I don't think he is um I think
he was the god of stories kind of in
these past two episodes yes right
rewriting it all right uh but not
overall now moving forward in the MCU I
don't think so uh Santiago moneg where
does the scar which prophecy F to this
that's a great question um I'm not sure
about that you know
[Music]
um
perhaps she undo something she can
affect realities in the Multiverse so
perhaps something she does uh will
ultimately affect Loki there who knows I
think that's I you know I heard once
um that I heard that that that they
haven't 100% decided on the story for
the Scarlet Witch in the MCU
yet so that very well could be what's
going on right now why we don't have any
more news about her uh
recently
if no timekeepers what about the Watcher
Daniel thanks for another Super Chat so
the timekeepers were always made up by K
by he who remains but uh The Watcher I
believe is going to enter the MCU
soon and and and kind of like Loki is
kind of a
Watchers
like he's kind of like a watcher now
Ronald sa too like Dark Souls Lore if
you know you know uh I don't know I'm
sorry oh my my
bad but thank you for that Super Chat uh
hold on I missed a few here so he has
God of stories or Avengers Prime I think
he was the god of stories in these past
two episodes I don't think he's writing
stories his own way now I think he's
just allowing the Multiverse and free
will to
exist and he he's not really an Avengers
Prime in the way that it goes in the
comics you could kind of call it like he
is the multiv
he is that entity now so you could
essentially he's kind of a cosmic entity
now right you have like
eternity and you
know just these other ones and yeah he
could essentially be time now or no he
wouldn't be Time Eternity I guess is
time I don't know what he would be now
but he he's essentially a cosmic entity
now Brandon Graham could luy show up now
and be the mcu's new Stanley
Cameo I I don't know if he can cam I
don't know if he can project himself
because I feel like he would have in
that last scene with Mobius and Sylvie
or maybe he simply just let
them let them
be right I mean
like maybe he can but he's like I I
won't interrupt this moment I'll just
observe I'll just be the Watcher that's
why I'm kind of saying like he's kind of
like the Watcher now not interfering
just letting it be you know James Ryan
how did the TVA not detect the Council
of Kang thanks for that super chat I
think that's because I mentioned this
little bit earlier I think that's
because
um so when you have I I explained the
difference before so when you have no
offense to Victor timely but smart
smarter Kang variants obviously Victor
Tomy was very smart more advanced Kang
variants who were born in like the 30th
31st Century uh they can figure out time
travel and do all that and they can
exist outside of space and time which I
think the Multiverse still does exist in
space and time Loki might exist outside
of space and time holding the Multiverse
together but other variants can also go
outside of space and time to different
points right it gets kind of complicated
and you know kind of existing in
different planes that Loki and the TVA
might not be able to detect uh Arrow
hunter games is that your full name
sorry it cut off thanks for that super
chat I really appreciate
that uh why can't I scroll anymore
Samuel Forest thanks for the super chat
if he remains as gone is Kings around
still also the Ant-Man 3 reference was
fun yes kangs are still around just not
the specific variant he who
remains I I believe Loki is kind of the
new He Who Remain slash The Watcher
slash the Multiverse itself uh yeah so I
think to answer that one question I
think that's how they don't detect Loki
because he
is or that how they don't detect the
Council of K as they exist outside of
space and time they're not in any of the
universes that compile the Multiverse
that Loki is monitoring and the TVA is
monitoring they're outside that's why
they don't detect
them so
yeah wow I mean I'm still just so blown
away y'all I'm still just so blown away
with how good that story writing was how
good this scene right here I
mean oh man what an
amazing what does it say right here hold
on and then I'll I'll go back to that
file what does it say here nurture
our nature for a stable
future what does it say nurture our
nature for a stable future interesting
all right let me go back to that file as
was
requested I passed
it was it this file that you wanted me
to oh my gosh I'm more capable Than This
I
Swear zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom
zoom
zoom this is this is Kang right here
hold on ah dang it hold on I can do
this yeah so the variance of he
remains uh so as you can see that's Kang
right
there yeah see that's Kang from Quantum
mania this is the device they use for
Quantum Mania
uh yeah you can see it there this was
the orb power thing that he used that
they shrunk
down but was it the other file for
Mobius that we were trying to look
at yeah this one right
here
I can't make it
out let me see if I can go a little bit
bigger uh
I I can't really make it out but I I I
think it's just Mobius as
file for the for who asked me to do that
in the Super Chat I think it's just
Mobius as file
trying to bring it back
down I don't think it's something I
don't think it's something else that we
were
uh see a few people are still asking
about the the god of
stories uh I don't think Loki I think
Loki was kind of the god of stories in
episode five and episode six but I don't
think he is now I don't think he's
writing any part of the
Multiverse d y l Lancaster thanks for
that super chat I really appreciate it
um Christian cvan thanks for that Super
Chat what if Loki creates the Watchers
so he can leave yo
that's not a bad
Theory I actually really like
that if he if if he doesn't like kind of
become it himself he kind of is the
Watcher Samuel Forest seen a lot of
people say Marvel is crap even on trolls
so does that mean it's just more Marvel
blah I I will say what I always say just
go watch it for yourself and form your
own opinion you you know um there's a
lot of reviews like the real rejects did
a review uh Jeremy John's I really like
he did he did a review on it I'll do a
review on it
uh
Saturday I haven't seen it yet guys I've
been sick so I didn't I didn't go I
didn't fly out for the screening since
I've been sick so I haven't seen it
yet so some of y'all are going to see it
before me Samuel thanks for another one
is this the end of Loki Loki's MCU
future just for Avengers King Dynasty or
Secret Wars maybe Deadpool I don't think
it's end of Loki I think Loki is going
to play a very important role in secret
Wars I think he's going to play a very
important role in secret
Wars
yeah
wow
well I
I I can't get over how I thought this
was fantastic y'all I just I can't get
over how amazing this was I got to watch
this thing again I got to watch it a lot
more times because I got to do my
breakdown on it and uh I mean I just I
can't believe what they did with it as
far as storytelling and writing and
everything I mean man it was
uh oh it was so much better than like I
thought it would be like it exceeded my
expectations
which as sad as it is I haven't had that
with Marvel in a really long time I
haven't had my expectations exceeded in
a really long time with Marvel so this
was super refreshing and I just think it
was amazing storytelling and I think
that's what Marvel's been missing lately
is really good
storytelling
right to to me Mr Anderson says the
Marvels was amazing and you know what I
I've I I have talked to people who seen
the movie and they said they were kind
of confused because I have talked to
people who did not like the movie but
they said the they said half the
audience loved it and half of the
audience actually hat hated it I can't
tell you cuz I don't know every single
person in here personally if you're
going to like it or not I can't tell you
which side you're going to be on you may
hate it like Greg Alaba of the real
rejects or you may like it like Mr
Anderson I can't tell you what side
you're gonna be on I don't know your
guys's taste I would just go see it you
know you know if if you can afford to
you know you want to go see it right now
go see it if not you can wait what it'll
probably be on Disney Plus in a month or
something right I mean uh you know you
you probably won't have to wait that
long I I I I sadly don't think it's
going to perform well and they're going
to move it to Disney plus pretty soon as
sad as that
is as sad as that is Will Samuel force
will Loki form the Avengers so I kind of
was like talking about this before in a
sense of Avengers Prime I was like it's
not going to be like one entity but Loki
might make like recruit The multiversal
Avengers team right so he'll form that
team I think he might you know I think
he might communicate with whoever is in
charge of the
TVA and kind of tell them that but
essentially Loki is staying out of
everything like he he is the Watcher
essentially now like he
is
he he is just allowing free will to
exist now throughout every single
universe and not interfering because
that was the deal was Kang he who
remains was interfering and that wasn't
Free Will so Loki and Sylvie they they
like episode one or season one of Loki
was all about Free Will Loki could not
stand the fact
that he didn't decide anything right so
that's really what this was all about
giving people true Free Will that's what
Loki did that's what Loki is currently
doing uh Zachary fit sea your name kind
of cut off there it's it just says fit
Simo is the is the last part I see so if
there's more to that I apologize so
basically Loki can now retry after
failures yeah although I think he's done
with that I think he did what he needed
needed to do and
he's the Multiverse now so hope that
kind of answers your question Sean
Kohl's thanks for another one the end
wasn't king girl about to find
Gall I don't know what that means I'm
sorry I uh Kang girl about to find Galla
was that
did somebody say something it it was
supposed to be that or something like
that I I I'm a little confused by that I
I do
apologize wow guys this is a I can't
believe this WOW uh while this uh uh no
chat's moving sorry Kamar Cummings thank
you so much for the Super Chat while
this season story is amazing it is a cop
out this didn't change anything in MCU
pre-u season 2 I new game yeah so I do
think they should have released Loki
season 2 like before quantam Mania and
stuff but these events did have to
happen right like Kang variant wouldn't
exist without Loki season 2 happening
and Loki now essentially gave people
free will like it's a big deal right
because no one's controlling anything it
was just one Universe one sacred
timeline before and he who remains was
controlling what happened he was writing
everything and you know I'll explain
this one last time before I get off and
my throat is getting very dry excuse
me being sick and talking a lot doesn't
uh always go hand in hand with each
other
um these were kind of the options at the
end one is If he if he killed Kang
everything that happened in Loki season
2 would happen and the time Loom would
explode and it would revert back just to
the sacred timeline like you said it's a
fail save so it would revert back to
just one sacred timeline the Multiverse
would not exist or he could kill Sylvie
and let Kang still control everything in
the one main
timeline Loki decided he didn't want any
of those options and he destroyed the
time Blom himself but kind of took its
place and he is now holding the
Multiverse together and allowing Free
Will so
I hope that kind of answers your
question I kind of agree with what you
said a little bit because this should
have came out
before Samuel Forest thanks for another
one do you think Ren Slayer is elath
void yeah I think elith got her I think
that's that's what that was at the end I
think aiia killed
her so yeah okay well I appreciate
everyone being here tonight
I I can't believe this story AR of Loki
I'm just going to I I'll end on this uh
also Let's uh if we could stop the super
chats because I don't want to miss any
because they're a little bit delayed uh
so you could give me a super chat I
might get off so I appreciate the Super
Chat so much we got one right here okay
let's stop the super chats because I
don't want to miss any um Ren Slayer
found aiath at the end of the show yes
exactly ex exactly exactly so
um yeah I
mean
this might be the greatest
Arc in MCU history and it's hard to say
that because of Iron Man right it's
really hard to say that because of Iron
Man
but man this was like think of where
Loki
started Tony Stark wasn't a villain he
was egotistical what narcissistic
billionaire play with you know he was
egotistical he was young he was he was
he was arrogant he was Reckless but he
wasn't evil he wasn't a villain Loki was
Loki wanted to rule everything and you
know what he remember what he said like
isn't this simpler like you know what I
mean people don't want free will it's
basically what he said in the first
Avengers movie now he is saying I'm
giving everyone Free
Will I he sacrificed himself for
literally everyone across every single
Universe there could possibly
be what an amazing story arc like I
can't
I can't praise the writing of this
enough I
mean
wow just Jack thanks for the Super Chat
yo honestly looky gonna beat king let's
be real we also gotta get call Remember
Me Oh Jack yeah dude yeah from the old
super chats yeah yeah yeah yeah we
talked on Instagram yeah dude I remember
you for sure for
sure yeah oh man I just I
I I can't wait to see what happens with
this with secret wars in the
future uh Primo Primo that file is
fantastic for 353 Mobius first
appearance oh I see what you're
saying
oh yeah I see what you're saying hold
on right hold up on I see what you're
saying I see what you're
saying yeah right here yeah it says it
right here it says
ff353
yo good catch it does say
that it does say that
yeah
so uh man I I wonder if that's just an
Easter
egg I so I can't can't screenshot on my
PC and zoom in it's really weird so uh
I'll have to look on that before I do
the breakdown obviously but hey thanks
thanks for that man appreciate that old
men are thanks for that Super Chat OB
said branches were dying and that it's
true unless Loki hold them right
branches are active as long as he holds
them yeah I guess so I guess Loki kind
of Enchanted them right again he's
literally allowing the Multiverse to
exist he he has become that essentially
yes the Tree of Life the Tree of Life To
The Multiverse which is crazy and it's
funny that Mr Anderson hasn't seen it
yet and we're just all sitting here
talking about it but I know you don't
mind
spoilers so yes he became the igil tree
he did really I
mean so Loki allow free will he he is
holding the Multiverse together
so they can exist it's crazy it's a lot
to wrap your head around really is but
uh
man I can't wait to to dive into
this I really can't wait to dive into
this so all right I'm gonna end the
super chat or yeah let's end the Super
Chat it's gonna end the live stream
because I got to start working on this
breakdown because it's it's probably
gonna be the same I'm G to do a lot of
different videos about it
so yeah wow I can't believe this can't
believe this I loved it so
much I really did Loki's Arc
is just this is like the best Arc in the
MCU it really is it's like the best
Arc for any character so all right guys
I'm logging out thank you to everyone
who was here tonight we had a lot of
Watchers tonight I super appreciate it
uh we haven't had this many
since the last Loki really uh W Division
and
Loki after those you know people stop
stopped doing watch parties and started
coming in and yeah I'm glad to see
everybody here tonight I hope this
really you
know brings back the spark for people
with the MCU because this was just like
great writing and we did this is what
the MCU needed we need more of this just
forever right just a lot lot more of
this so thank you to everybody uh I
really I really love this this was a
special moment tonight thank you for
sharing it with me uh everybody who was
watching everybody who was chatting
thank you I'm sorry I can't get to
obviously you know re read everyone that
uh everyone that that talks but also uh
thank you all for the super chats as
well I hope I got them all if I didn't
I'm sorry I TR I do truly apologize I I
scrolled through the chat and tried to
get all of them but uh yeah it was
insane it was insane can't wait to see
what the future holds can't wait to see
what deadpol 3 holds that's gonna be
crazy so yeah but anyways thank you to
everybody so much Mr Anderson thanks for
coming in uh even though you were
watching the Marvels I I you already
told me though so I I knew what it was
going to be but thanks for jumping in at
the end hope you watch it and like it
hope uh everybody rewatches this cuz it
was so good and I look out for some
breakdowns coming in a couple hours and
tomorrow and probably a lot more in the
next few days uh as I rewatch this and
dive into it and you know people put
theories out there and stuff like that
so thank you so much everybody for
dropping by I will catch you all in our
next video woof woof